il y a deux ans je rencontrais une
semaine j'ai aimé mes hommes mariés
bonjour je suis célibataire elle ne
laisse pas beaucoup de gens ben non ok
raconté qu'il avait perdu une femme oui
car le tas j'aurai le parti où ça c'est
jésus 28 pensent ça fait 20 ans mais
cyril sebas jalouse d'affrontements
vous êtes souvient la compagnie semelle
oui je suis sa femme
carlotta je crois que j'ai fait car
l'état ne parle pas de carottage
entendent parler d'elle errant fille
elle t'attend bas c'est moi oui ça fait
combien de temps modernes ont huit mois
et 6 jours
j'aurais pas qu'elles sont mortes
existe plus
j'ai besoin de toi moi j'ai pas besoin
de toi
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu es venu faire ici
gauche quoi tout ça
je te plaît quand même
quand même
à l'arrivée je suis terrifiée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je te fasse
arrête toi
vous devez aller au ministère public les
annuleront de jugement vous pourrez
récupérer votre patrimoine ce que je
peux récupérer mon mari
[Musique]